-Let's get to the news.
House Democrats released a cop
of an eight-page resolutio
they will vote on this Thursda
to formalize
the impeachment inquiry.
Ah, yes, the old
"make it so long
trump won't read it" trick
[ Laughter ]
[as Trump] I'm supposed to rea
eight pages by Thursday?
What do I look like,
a library person?
[ Laughter ]
President Trump
and First Lady Melania Trump
hosted trick-or-treaters
at the White House yesterday
and gave out full-sized
Hershey bars
and the kids were
super excited,
until they got the bill.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Trump and Melani
held a Halloween event
at the White House.
Melania handed out candy,
[laughing]
while Trump took it back.
[ Laughter ]
[as Trump] Sorry, kid,
executive privilege.
[ Laughter, clapping ]
No, I don't want the candy corn.
You can keep the --
[ Laughter ]
During the event,
President Trump and Melani
passed out candy
to trick-or-treaters
on the White House lawn.
I'm guessing
for the first time?!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Why?
Why are you puttin' it
on his head?!
[as Trump] Alright.
I'll give this banana
in overalls some candy,
but I'm not --
I am not bendin' over for it
[ Laughter ]
Apple added 400 new emojis
to iPhones yesterday,
including a pinching hand used
to suggest
that something is small.
Said men, "So, what,
she wants me to buy only
a little bit of eggplant?"
[ Laughter ]
What do you think that means
What?!
The University of Arizona
announced yesterday
that it'll be changing
its abbreviation from UA
to U Arizona in an attempt
to differentiate itself
from United Airlines.
It will also differentiate
itself from United Airline
by providing meals.
[ Laughter ]
A town in Ireland
broke a Guinness World Recor
this weekend
by gathering over 1,000 people
dressed like Harry Potter
and if you wanna see
1,000 people
who look like Ron Weasley,
just go to any town
in Ireland, anytime.
[ Laughter ]